am i early I came on time as to avoid
the cuts and dogs outside so no one
dressed flooding old-timey I did well
I'm already having fun and much as I
loved the bike ride over here oh by the
way I I got a new bike I know I moved it
what is going on here
I thought you said this was mandatory
Timothy that's what the letter that I
got says got a letter to reassign Keynes
on the bookshelf Addante me anything
though
welcome to the murder mystery escape
room oh are you serious
come on this turnout sucks but I invited
like a hundred and a half people you did
this yes
all right you guys I'm getting us a
horse we never know I promise it only
fun wait
Timothy you're gonna be professor great
oh I've always wanted to be a professor
you can be just sexy maid Oh what have
sex Billy you can be Miss Charlotte I
was just a stupid name yes you know
you're my favorite Colonel mayonnaise no
no no no I'm not
and you're mrs. pussy-willow I love
pussies I have a Scottish Fold okay I
think I speak for almost everyone here
when I say that no one's into this plant
you have 60 minutes to figure out all
the clues and unlock all the locks
including this lock on this very door or
else you'll never escape the room your
time starts now
follow me you idiot
oh my god she's choking on Oh
oh they make that look so easy to kids
movies how are we supposed to get out
now gene you figure out the clues and
then you use the music right right I
thought that would work
wait a minute we need when you have a
key where's windy my oven quick play
Oh Wendy take off your hair do you have
a spare key
Wendy left already do I know you
I mean yes you do you recommend that I
not be hired by your call do you work
here now did you have I did great
welcome to welcome month the Lord why
you don't see bother but they still
wanna be